Morning, John.
Sometimes I forget that not everyone in America is like me
and in fact, most people do not live their lives
on the internet.
Like, there are lots of people in America
who still have dial-up internet,
who've never streamed a video,
who think that LOL stands for "lots of love",
which, tangentially, is a very dangerous mistake to make.
It can lead to emails like,
"Dear Lynn,
I was so sorry to hear
of the passing of your wonderful Golden Retriever.
And it's times like these, that we must take comfort in God's love.
Lol, Margaret."
So yeah,
Katherine's parents are here visiting
and they have never had a high-speed internet in their lives.
They seem very interested and supportive when I try to explain to them what it is that I do,
but it's obvious that, more or less,
we're talking different languages.
Honestly, I can't figure out why they're so nice about it.
I mean, if my daughter married a dude who is like,
"Sorry, I can't go out to the lunch
I have to go talking to a camera
and flail my arms around."
I don't think I would be very friendly to that guy
and I have a 10 megabit per second download.
So they don't get it.
But I guess they don't have to
because they're really nice about it anyway.
So thanks to them for that.
Also Katherine's brother and her sister-in-law and their son,
our nephew who's 4 years old,
are also in town,
which makes for a big group of people.
And John, I have to tell you,
four-year-olds...
in whatever amount of time between now and when Henry is 4,
you've got some preparations to do.
Because Bill Cosby was right,
they have
[Bill Cosby]: Brain damage!
One second, he's like,
"Uncle Hank, I love you.
Let's play go fish."
And I'm like,
"That sounds like a wonderful idea.
Let's play go fish."
And then five minutes later, I'm like,
"Do you have any jacks?"
And then he's all,
[Demon voice]: "I will torture your soul for an eternity of hellfire.
Now sit in awe
as I make a noise that will kill all the dolphins."
[Shriek noise]
But mostly,
you know aside from the dolphin killing,
he's very fun.
Seriously though,
we hang out
and we eat
and he's funny
and he's cute and
I've been going to sleep way earlier than is natural for my body,
He wakes up at 6 o'clock in the morning,
every morning.
What kind of demon does that?
Sleep, friend!
(sleep!)
Also, I'm trying to teach him the meaning of words like
perseverance
and relaxation.
But ooo...
he does not get either of those ideas at all.
Trying to get the idea of relaxation across to him
is very confusing, I think.
It- it's this thing
that you can do
that's actually not doing anything.
You just don't do stuff.
You just... chill.
Which does not compute because of the brain damage.
And with perseverance,
he pretty much would rather not be doing whatever it is he's doing
and he would like to be doing whatever it is that he
cannot
do.
Not allowed!
Why did this video turn into a video about a four year old?
But I do have to tell you one last thing he is obsessed with:
his poops.
Particularly with the size of his poops
and he also assumes that,
likewise you will be very interested in the size of his poops.
Anyway,
the slow pace of development of human children
is a side effect of our reliance upon cultural and not genetic evolution
and that is the very thing that makes people so amazing
and so awesome
and so unique.
So I guess,
it would be foolish of me to complain about it.
So everybody,
I think that my nephew was curious,
how has your poop been lately?
John,
I will see you on Monday.